Il y a presque deux ans,
j'étais en Allemagne au volant de ma voiture,
et j'écoutais la radio.
L'Europe était en pleine crise de l'Euro,
et la dégradation de la note des pays européens,
par les agences de notation situées aux États-Unis,
faisait la une dans tous les médias.
En écoutant, je me demandais :
« Qu'est-ce que c'est que ces agences de notation,
et pourquoi leur travail provoque-t-il autant de bouleversements ? »
Hé bien, si vous aviez été assis
à côté de moi, dans la voiture, ce jour-là
et si vous m'aviez dit que je passerais
les prochaines années à essayer de changer le système,
il est évident que je vous aurais traité de fou.
Mais vous savez ce qui est réellement fou :
c'est la manière dont ces agences sont gérées.
Et j'aimerais vous expliquer
non seulement pourquoi il est temps de changer cela,
mais aussi, comment nous pouvons le faire.
Laissez-moi vous parler un peu de
ce que font réellement ces agences de notation.
De la même manière que vous lisez un magazine automobile
avant d'acheter une nouvelle voiture,
ou lisez les commentaires clients,
avant de décider quelle sorte de tablette ou téléphone acheter,
les investisseurs prennent connaissance des notes attribuées
avant de décider dans quel type de produit
ils vont investir leur argent.
Les notations partent du AAA,
pour les produits ayant la qualité de crédit la plus élevée,
et peuvent descendre jusqu'au BBB -,
pour les investissements plutôt risqués.
Les agences de notation notent les entreprises.
Elles notent les banques.
Elles notent même les produits financiers
comme les inqualifiables créances hypothécaires titrisées.
Mais elles peuvent également noter des pays,
ces notations sont appelées « notations souveraines »,
et j'aimerais m'attarder plus particulièrement
sur ces notations souveraines.
Je sais ce que vous vous dites en m'écoutant,
vous pensez :
« pourquoi devrais-je me soucier de ça ? », n'est-ce pas ?
Soyez honnête.
Les notations vous concernent.
Elles nous touchent tous.
Si une agence de notation note un pays,
elle mesure et évalue de manière intrinsèque
la dette de ce pays,
ainsi que la capacité et la volonté du pays
à rembourser sa dette.
Donc si un pays voit sa note dégradée par les agences de notation,
le pays devra payer plus
lorsqu'il voudra emprunter de l'argent
sur les marchés internationaux.
Cela vous concerne en tant que citoyen et en tant que contribuable,
parce que vous et vos compatriotes
allez devoir débourser plus dans le but d'emprunter.
Mais que ce passe-t-il si le pays ne peut se permettre de payer plus,
parce que c'est devenu trop cher ?
Hé bien, le pays a moins d'argent disponible
pour les autres services, comme les routes, les écoles, la santé.
C'est pour cela que vous êtes concernés,
parce que les notations souveraines nous touchent tous.
C'est la raison pour laquelle je crois
qu'elles devraient être reconnues comme étant un bien public.
Elles devraient être transparentes, accessibles,
et disponibles gratuitement pour tous.
Mais voilà ce qu'il en est réellement :
le marché des agences de notation est dominé
par trois acteurs et seulement trois :
Standard and Poor's, Moody's et Fitch.
Nous savons que chaque fois qu'il y a concentration économique,
il n'y a plus aucune concurrence.
Plus rien n'incite à améliorer
la qualité de votre produit.
Et soyons clair, les notations financières de ces agences,
ont contribué à amener l'économie mondiale au bord du gouffre,
elles doivent changer la manière dont elles travaillent.
Le deuxième point :
achèteriez-vous vraiment une voiture
en vous basant uniquement sur les conseils du vendeur ?
Évidemment que non, n'est-ce pas ? Ce serait irresponsable.
Mais c'est exactement ce qui se passe
tous les jours, au sein des agences de notation.
Les clients de ces agences,
comme les pays ou les entreprises,
payent pour leurs propres notations,
il est évident que cela crée
un conflit d'intérêts.
Le troisième point est le suivant :
ces agences de notation ne nous disent pas vraiment
comment elles procèdent pour noter.
Alors que de nos jours,
vous ne pouvez vendre une barre chocolatée
sans en lister tous les ingrédients.
En ce qui concerne les notations,
un élément capital de notre économie,
nous ne connaissons
aucun des ingrédients utilisés.
Nous donnons le droit aux agences de notation
d'être complètement opaques sur leur manière de travailler.
Changer cela devient une nécessité.
Je pense, sans l'ombre d'un doute,
que le secteur nécessite un remaniement complet,
et pas une simple révision.
Je pense qu'il faut faire preuve d'audace,
et qu'il est temps de s'attaquer au problème.
Et c'est pourquoi, à la Fondation Bertelsmann,
nous avons investi beaucoup de temps et de travail
à réfléchir à de nouvelles solutions.
Et nous avons développé le premier modèle
d'Agence de Notation du risque souverain à but non lucratif.
Nous l'appelons : INCRA ( International Credit Rating Agency )
INCRA créerait une différence
avec le système actuel,
en incluant un partenaire à but non lucratif au sein de ce groupe d'agences.
Elle serait basée sur un modèle non lucratif,
et financée par un fonds d'investissement à long terme.
Le fonds d'investissement créerait des dividendes
qui nous permettraient de couvrir les coûts de fonctionnement de l'agence.
Cela nous permettrait également de rendre nos notations publiques.
Mais tout ceci ne suffit pas à faire la différence.
Le fonctionnement d'INCRA serait basé
sur une structure juridique et organisationnelle transparente
qui rendrait impossible tout conflit d'intérêts.
Elle inclurait un grand nombre de parties prenantes
issues de la société.
INCRA ne serait pas seulement
une agence de notation
américaine ou européenne.
Elle serait une agence véritablement internationale
dans laquelle les économies émergentes
seraient réellement représentées
au même titre que les autres.
La deuxième grande différence
se situe au niveau de l'évaluation du risque souverain,
basé sur un grand nombre d'indicateurs.
Imaginez que nous établissions une notation
en s'intéressant uniquement
à la valeur économique des terres agricoles du pays.
C'est un des indicateurs macro-économiques fondamentaux.
Mais nous devons aussi nous demander :
qui travaille cette terre ?
Un pays a beaucoup de jardiniers,
et l'un d'entre eux est le gouvernement.
Donc nous devons nous demander
comment est géré et administré le pays ?
C'est la raison pour laquelle,
nous avons développé
ce que nous appelons des « indicateurs prospectifs ».
Ces indicateurs permettent
une lecture très précise
du développement socio-économique du pays.
J'espère que vous serez d'accord, si je dis
qu'il est important pour vous de savoir
si votre gouvernement souhaite investir dans
les énergies renouvelables et l'éducation.
Si le gouvernement de votre pays
est capable de gérer une crise,
si le gouvernement est capable
de mettre en place les réformes promises.
Par exemple,
si INCRA devait évaluer l'Afrique du Sud,
il est certain que nous étudierions avec précision
le taux de chômage des jeunes dans le pays.
Le plus élevé au monde.
Si plus de 70% de la population de moins de 35 ans
est au chômage,
il est évident que cela a un énorme impact
sur l'économie, présente et future.
Nos amis de Moody's, Standard and Poor's et Fitch
nous diraient qu'ils prennent aussi cela en compte.
Mais devinez quoi,
nous ne savons pas exactement
comment ils procèderaient.
Ce qui m'amène à la troisième différence notable
apportée par INCRA.
INCRA ne ferait pas seulement paraître ses notations,
mais elle communiquerait également sur
ses indicateurs et sa méthodologie.
Contrairement au système actuel,
INCRA serait complètement transparente.
En résumé,
INCRA offrirait une alternative
au système actuel
aux mains des trois grandes agences de notation
en incorporant au groupe
un partenaire à but non lucratif.
Ceci aurait pour effet
d'accroître la compétition,
la transparence et la qualité
au sein de ce secteur.
Même si les notations souveraines
vous paraissent toujours
être une toute petite partie
de ce monde globalisé de la finance,
je peux vous assurer
que c'est une partie extrêmement importante
et qu'il est nécessaire d'y apporter des changements.
Les notations souveraines
nous concernent tous.
Elle doivent être considérées
comme des biens publics.
C'est pour cela que
nous sommes en train de tester notre modèle.
Nous cherchons à regrouper
des partenaires
capables et désireux
de faire voir le jour à INCRA.
Je suis totalement convaincue
de l'utilité d'un tel projet.
Créer INCRA
est dans l'intérêt de tous.
Nous avons la possibilité, maintenant
de transformer INCRA
en pierre d'angle
d'un nouveau système financier ouvert à tous.
Cela fait déjà trop longtemps
que nous laissons les acteurs financiers seuls.
Il est temps de leur apporter un peu de compagnie.
Merci
(Applaudissements)